Denis wolfies from the Women's Business
Council is with me now a very warm
welcome to use Denis Denis not Dave I
should say what was your assessment of
the gender pay data that came out well I
think it's very good that we've got to
measure at long last I think your daddy
took what gets measured gets done and I
think it provides a very good basis for
measurement of improvement as we go
forward through the years clearly it's
the first time through and there are
those who came out of it a lot worse
than al yeah and you know it's a it's a
first time through but I think the big
picture is clearly there's a lot to do
and this toolkit that you've developed
and what exactly is it and who's it
directed at so it's aimed at CEOs of
footsie 350 and other prominent
businesses in the UK and the reason that
we've chosen to pitch it that way is
because certainly in my experience yet
changing businesses happen when the
senior leadership and particularly the
CEO prioritize it you've got some
prominent CEOs who have signed up
including our own Jeremy Derek but as we
know gender pay gaps aren't so much
about equal pay but they show up the
fact that you just don't have as many
women in senior high high paying roles
how does how exactly do you go about
making that happen what are the most
effective tools for making that happen
getting more women in those roles well I
think working with the pipeline is very
important so what we've chosen to focus
on in in the report is what we've called
a3 asks of the CEO what one of them is
to make achieving 33% of the executive
teams being women by 2020 the second
which I think is very important is to
personally sponsor one to three women
from within the organisation we've got
the capability to fulfill those roles to
really help them come through and to
make sure they get the opportunities and
the development necessary to do so and
then the third thing is to be vocal in
the wider business community about the
need for change I think you know
transparency is very important here to
be honest about the challenges that
businesses individually and collectively
and what needs to be done and then to
have the drive and the resolve to do
something about it I suppose a cynic
might say a toolkit it sounds nice it
sort of gives you a good blueprint about
how you should be doing things but
things don't change overnight firstly
and they don't often change unless there
are penalties for not doing things so is
there an argument that you should make
CEOs pay or bonus dependent on
delivering and some of those pledges
that you were talking about well I think
it's absolutely essential that
businesses for their own success into
the future deal with these issues
because they need to remain relevant to
their stakeholders whether it's their
employees or their customers or
regulators and so on so I think there is
an absolute vested interest for CEOs to
make sure that these things are
delivered and increasingly boards will
hold management teams more accountable
to make sure that they are delivered but
I think the question really is how and
what we've tried to address in our
report isn't isn't a pipe dream type
stuff we've we've showcased
organizations that have actually made a
really good start and whilst I'm sure
they would say that they've got a long
way to go they're already showing some
success and have you had any bosses
who've just not been terribly receptive
to these ideas I'm not asking you to
name and shame them I'm just wondering
how our responsive people have been it's
certainly true that there's a mixed bag
so one of the purposes of the report and
by enlisting the support of CEOs who are
already putting these ideas into into
practice is to get the attention and
inspire those a little bit behind the
curve I think by sharing best practice
sharing ideas and if you like
normalizing this as a key business
priority we're much more likely to make
more progress more quickly